ant-man and the wasp is once again
directed by Peyton Reed the man behind
the first film and stars Paul Rudd and
Evangeline Lilly and Michael Douglas
Laurence Fishburne Michael Pena TI and
some other really talented people and
this follows ant-man as he is on his
last few days of house arrest after the
events of Civil War he gets brief
visitations with his daughter and he is
looking forward to so much getting that
ankle bracelet off and finally being
able to leave the house and be the
father he wants to be but adventure
comes calling as Hank Pym and hope are
trying to locate their mother and wife
respectively who was lost in the quantum
realm they believed her to still be
alive and they think that Scott Lang can
help them find her I actually really
enjoyed the first ant-man and I
rewatched it before I did this review I
have the 3d blu-ray and the 3d looks
amazing even on the blu-ray that was a
film one of the very few that I actually
recommended seeing in 3d and I still
really liked that movie I think it's a
very good narrative it's very fun and
lightweight and it feels kind of
refreshing and it's an enjoyable film
despite its kind of cookie cutter
villain and this sequel is similar to
the first in one specific way and that
is that it's just a very easygoing film
this movie doesn't feel like it has a
lot of darkness behind it it's certainly
not a sad experience it's pretty much
the polar opposite of that this movie
seems designed almost to just be fun and
I feel like the film might get a lot of
extra credit for that coming off of
infinity war because that's a very grim
film that was very intense
and left a lot of people depressed not
because it was bad but simply because of
the outcome of the finale and so people
are now wondering what's going on with
the heroes and everything and so purely
based off of the timing of its release I
feel like this movie is going to get a
lot of credit for not being as dark and
being a lot more enjoyable which is kind
of an interesting viewpoint because I
feel like in the future when people pop
in ant-man on the wasp to watch it for
the first time they're not going to be
thinking well infinity war had just come
out and I'm really depressed about that
they're just gonna want to judge the
film on its merits they may have just
watched the first film and they'll
compare it to that but I wouldn't say
that this film is better simply because
Infinity Ward just came out and this
movie feels sort of refreshing in that
way
that being said for almost the entire
runtime of ant-man in the wasp I found
myself mildly entertained it's not quite
as good as the first film I don't think
the narrative isn't as strong this time
around I felt quite a bit for Scott Lang
in the first film in his plight with
trying to reconnect with his daughter
his criminal past that takes a major
backseat to this film his criminal past
and it's mostly about him trying to
sneak out while he's on house arrest and
quite a bit of character given to hope
or the wasp who is definitely a
highlight of the film you could say she
steals the whole movie but I feel like
that term is reserved for a character
that wasn't supposed to but ends up
stealing the film like an Ian Malcolm in
Jurassic Park I don't think that
character was written to steal the whole
movie but Jeff Goldblum came in there
and he stole the whole film or Benicio
del Toro in the first Sicario that
character stole the movie in the case of
ant-man in the wasp it feels very much
so designed for her to be the highlight
and it wisely builds off of her
character's frustration in the first
movie with not being able to go out into
action because her father was very
protective of her and at the end of that
film spoilers if he hadn't seen Ant Man
for some reason at the end of that film
you know she sees her costume and so it
sets that up well but Ant Man kind of
takes a backseat and makes a lot of
mistakes in the movie and kind of comes
off like a bumbling idiot which I didn't
really like because he's shown in the
first film to be extremely smart when it
comes to crafting tech and breaking into
houses he knows parkour and all this
amazing stuff before he even gets the
suit and then he adapts to the suit very
quickly and even defeats the Falcon on
their first initial encounter it feels
almost like they retcon Scott Lang in
this film to be more of a bumbling guy
which I didn't particularly like to be
honest Michael Douglas is once again
really good as Hank Pym I've always
liked that character but I specifically
like Douglas as that character and just
like in the first they have some
incredible flashback sequences with
de-aging effects it's really amazing
what people are able to do nowadays with
computers and it doesn't look like Tron
Legacy or anything like it's it's very
realistic Michael Pena once again is
terrific as a supporting character I
really really like
him he's very funny this movie is pretty
hilarious at times it has a nice kind of
easygoing feel like I said but for most
of the movie I felt like I would buy the
blu-ray and I was fine with it although
it felt very middle-of-the-road from me
and then something happens towards the
end that I can't get into because it'll
ruin it for you and it really doesn't
make sense and they never truly try to
explain what occurs and even if it was
in the comics and it's not in this film
that's not fair because there's gonna be
thousands upon thousands who watched
this movie who've never picked up an
ant-man comic in their entire life and
so you can't rely on the knowledge of
the comics to make your film better and
there's something that occurs towards
the end of the film that I'm fine with
occurring but then you better damn well
explain how all of this happened and
they don't I saw this film on June 26th
and I could have posted my review the
very next day but I've waited this long
because I wanted to double-check whether
or not I missed something I wanted to
see the film again because there are
very specific plot elements involving
Janet Van Dyne s character which the
trailers and the posters have let us
know that that is Michelle Pfeiffer and
I want to talk more about this in a
spoiler video very soon but it is very
frustrating for me because these plot
elements are imperative to how I feel
about the film overall but I can't get
into them here as far as villains go
there's a character named ghosts that
can sort of phase in and out of things
go through materials kind of reminded me
of the twins from the Matrix Reloaded
that characters backstory was intriguing
but the development for the character in
the present not so much
there's also another villain played by
Walton Goggins and his involvement in
the film feels so inconsequential and
forgettable in the long run that I
almost think the character could be
deleted and a few things shifted and the
film would have been better as a result
it's more fast paced than the first film
and it feels lighter than the first film
but it's at the expense of a stronger
narrative with better characters and
even though it is an entertaining film
that I'm sure a lot of people will enjoy
watching
it's very lazy when it comes to actually
explaining things that happen in the
film this film just hopes that you'll
accept it and it kind of soured me on
the whole experience I'm gonna give
ant-man in the wasp
plus I like the first film a lot and I
liked a lot of this movie too until the
third act it just started to go downhill
for me after that there's a couple end
credits sequences the first one you
should definitely see the second one you
don't really have to but let me know you
guys thought of ant-man in the wasp if
you do get a chance to see it thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck man eyes
[Music]